what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to alban preach's title
um video cheating may not
be your fault
uh before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos all right let's let's get going
oh also please subscribe i'm moving to
england in like a month um
i'm trying to get there it's been rough
let me tell you
also in the black community oh no i hate
the real i hate the real you know i
don't speak for the black community but
i do think that a lot of black men they
really don't know how to have true
faithful relationships they think
because they have money because they
have power that they can treat women any
kind of way
some can let me tell you
look at nick cannon
he's still getting baby mamas
like
come on
and that
is something we need to work on we need
to work on that money
here's something that's really messed up
what i was researching this and you guys
may not even like this part of the
conversation oh wow oh wow so here's
interesting rich people cheat more
poorer people cheat less
okay black people would predominantly
come from lower socioeconomic
backgrounds so i thought it was
interesting that despite that we still
yeah but here's the other thing that's
messed up
i actually was looking up cheating
statistics um after i went on fresh and
fixed i was just curious to like look
into it further and i found a couple
studies that said like cheating is at
the same rate but i also found a couple
studies that say it's about like 10
higher in the black community
um
yeah i don't know so do that what you
will so i had read this study a long
time ago that said that people with
elevated levels of testosterone are more
likely to be
single more likely to cheat more likely
to be in non-monogamous relationships
and so that i looked it up and then
college students black and white were
compared black
that would make sense
[Music]
another fun fact is um
men that are lower in the trait
agreeableness tend to make more money
but they're also more likely to cheat
because they're less likely
to agree
to not cheat you know
yeah so
biology we even did it in the bathroom
i told you they're not ready
do you wanna
[Music]
it's biology keeping it low
because i can't keep the chemistry
anymore oh
wow
remix biology
i'm sorry you [ __ ] food it's not your
fault man
it's not it's biology
so
[Music]
reality oh wow rob this study messed me
up because i was coming into this video
like what am i going to say this stuff
but but it is what i thought and then
they did a cross study with people in
africa you just found the same thing
people with higher levels of
testosterone were more likely even in
africa so it wasn't just a matter of
cultural where you are it was done
across so that became super interesting
to me and then you know with
testosterone they're still hypothesizing
why those people are more prone he gave
excuse to a whole bunch of people i know
but let's also not kill ourselves our
biology is not necessarily an excuse to
just automatically do whatever you want
yeah really it does influence it does
raise the likelihood but it doesn't mean
it's the only factor that determines
what kind of behavior you're going to
engage in and so i'm just laying down
all the information of what i found i
didn't want to hide anything from you
guys whether i wanted to or not we need
to work on it that money and power does
not mean that you can just do it i think
exactly in so many cultures that is the
whole machismo thing like that that goes
across the board but i'm gonna say it's
not across the board because what is
happening is and because our families
were broken up we still do not have an
idea of how to have together the
families because our families were
broken up yeah and until we really saw
perspective
she's basing herself from which she
lived
so it's hard for me to go against where
she lives i'm not saying that that's the
case but that's what you live that's one
thing now what you live it's not
necessarily an indication of what the
reality of what it is certain perception
i believe in surprise the board and
that's a machismo thing first you get
the money
then you get the power and you get the
respect people abuse of that you men
that are in position of power abusing
them
i don't think it's a black thing it's a
thing so you're saying people with money
no i think manchester it's not just men
not black men not black women it's
people cheap i've seen it left i've seen
that right so you don't think it has an
influence
it might be what do you think about that
well the facts are pretty clear people
with more money way more mentally men or
women
men more
men more than me and with more money
cheat more than women with more money
if you're talking about just generally
speaking at a younger age more than men
okay once you get older well i'd say
it's because both have more opportunity
like younger women have more opportunity
when they're young rich men have more
opportunities
obviously it's not surprising so women
cheat more and younger and then managing
yeah so because obviously they're in
their prime years and so in their
younger years it's a lot more accessible
it's a lot easier with less risk as you
get older you want to settle down the
prospect of a family becomes dimmer you
don't have as many
suitors the opposite way exactly as men
get into their prime they have more
options
i don't want to get old
the menosphere has made me realize that
the future is not bright
infidelity is different for men and
women for men infidelity is a matter of
options generally speaking as men have
more options their likelihood to cheat
raises dramatically and so that's why
you see the successful man with money
power influence uh infidelity's final
cut and this is a statistical event
women tend to cheat at least within
marriages and relationships due to
dissatisfaction either within the
bedroom or emotionally so we cheat for
different reasons uh but you do see that
women at younger ages when the option is
there and when they are more viable do
cheat more than men they got more
options they're just better at hiding it
so it doesn't seem like that perception
you know got more options
options
it is what it is so
we're speaking in generalities i don't
want people to come and be like actually
i cheat well into my 30s
let me get it okay there's there's
exceptions i'm talking about the bell
curve it doesn't mean it's a blanket
here's the thing with her comment she's
not wrong but she's not entirely right
when she says
black man cheat a lot you have to
understand that's her reality because
she's around black people
you know i mean it's like people that
say well black people do a lot of crime
against black people white people do a
lot of crimes against white people
asians against asians you know what i
mean so that's why it's a matter of
proximity and so if you see infidelity
around you if you're only around black
people you're going to assume it's a
more black people problem when you
reality if you go to latino countries
tell them
why me boy you listen to bachata
you don't listen to bachata i hate that
[ __ ] yo
dramatic ass music for no reason about
infidelity
epstein myself and this everything is a
it's just a thing it's just like
hey so yeah you want to go out i'm like
don't you have a boyfriend
is anyone else that [ __ ]
like
there was a guy in college who tried to
hook up with me and literally just
screenshotted it and sent it to his
girlfriend
i will i don't care but within a north
american context to back her up it is
true that statistically speaking uh
black men do cheat more than the other
races i think latinos were like a really
close second i thought that the black
men did cheat black boys not black men
shout out to charlemagne the guy
overall i just think that when it comes
to discussion basically what was her
claim her claim was that uh we don't
know how to fall we have a problem and
we have to work on it that's what you
said
i think everybody needs to work on their
faithfulness because i'll be honest with
you if you go to latin american
countries if you go to some parts of
europe infidelity's just ingrained in
the culture it's just more so than here
you would be shocked it's just
it's just a thing it's just it's just
the thing so
you know i think it's a mixture of
things i think it's a mixture of culture
biology it's a lot of things it's a
mixture of culture
biology and a lot of different things
but you know
i think when it comes to these
discussions all we can do is work on
ourselves as individuals try to set a
good example and try to not engage in
the behavior that we think is negative
sadly
so yeah pretty much all like anything
else you want to add about
not man that's pretty much it i told you
that he was going to listen
to that
messed you up
i think it's character like a character
is rare i don't think most people do the
right thing when there's no consequences
so it just it depends on your character
man
all right guys
fun video
oh my gosh
um i thought that was an interesting
video they're funny i love admin
preacher hilarious but let me know in
the comments what you guys think about
cheating um do you think it has to do
with your personality and your
testosterone or do you think it's more
just a choice don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
bell and i'll talk to you guys next time